we have a very interesting new poll uh
out of quinnipiac university about
whether
republicans want donald trump to remain
involved in american politics and in
republican party politics for the
foreseeable future and the answer
is yes they do yes they do
three-quarters of republicans
want donald trump to continue playing a
prominent
role in the republican party the poll
showed
89 percent of republicans opposed the
conviction of donald trump
in his senate second senate impeachment
trial
87 percent of republicans say trump
should be allowed to hold public office
in the future 89 percent of republicans
believe trump was not responsible for
inciting the violence that led to the
january 6th
riots and among all americans polled
55 percent opposed trump republican uh
returning to public office so this is a
very
important um number
because we talked last week or the week
before
about 64 percent of republicans saying
if trump left the party uh
and started his own party we would
follow him
nearly two-thirds of the republican
party has
such soft support for the party or has
simply accepted donald trump as the sort
of lord and savior
deity head of the party at this point
that they would follow him
out of it that's not so good for the
republican party
as an institution but it's certainly
good if you're donald trump and you want
to control
the republican party or american
politics going forward
now we learn that although there are
some republicans who would not leave the
republican party to follow trump
many of them do want trump to continue
involved
in american politics now one important
caveat is that
we know from our conversation with david
shore a few weeks ago
that republicans who answer the phone
and talk to pollsters
are not necessarily representative of
all republicans and and david shore
believes that
some of the more trumpy and q anon
conspiracy types may be refusing to
participate
in polls of course pollsters try to and
believe they have
ways of accounting and adjusting for
that but david shore was skeptical that
they really are great at it so that's
something something to understand
but assuming these numbers are roughly
accurate
this is really bad for republicans as a
party they
lost the presidential election by almost
eight million people
and at this point in time
most of them want trump to stay involved
and two-thirds
are even willing to leave the party i
don't know
how the math works out for them and what
i mean by that is
if you lose a national election by 8
million
in great part because of the guy who's
at the head of the party donald trump
failing on coronavirus turning off so
many traditional republicans you lose by
8 million
and then you want that guy to stay
involved and if he leaves the party
you'll leave with him
those are not numbers that bode well for
the republican party in national
elections now
at the local level it's a very different
situation you can still
you know the trumpian factor in
extremely red areas that would
never consider voting for for example a
democratic senator it may in practice
not have that big of an impact
but for as long as donald trump is so
prominent
it looks really tough for the republican
party to win
national elections and i'm glad to have
my mind changed but i don't see how the
numbers work out
now as a matter of sort of following the
nature
the easy nature by which so many
republican voters were bamboozled by
donald trump
they fell for the populist sounding
rhetoric back in 2015 and 2016. we've
talked about that many times yeah they
fell for it and then trump didn't do it
but they still don't seem to realize
that trump has done nothing
for just your average working class
republican beyond yes making them
really afraid of others that are going
to do bad things to you
china undocumented immigrants democrats
communists marxists anarchists or
anarchists as donald trump would call
them
yeah he stoked fears for the average
working-class republican really well
he told them lies about the things he
would do said he would fix trade he
didn't do it
said he would build a wall across the
entire u.s mexico border he didn't do it
said he would replace obamacare with a
beautiful new health care plan didn't do
it
so fear false promises
a coalescing the most hateful elements
of the republican party
but they still seem not to realize that
he did nothing for them
economically the way he claimed to do
and now as we know 40 percent of
coronavirus deaths during the trump
administration were unnecessary and
avoidable so of course all of the
numbers wow
how does the republican party win
national elections in these
circumstances but the the other question
is
millions tens of millions still don't
realize trump didn't do any of the
things he said he would do for the
working class do they care do they not
no i'm not sure
i don't know the answer but if they
never wake up to it
support for trump in the republican
party is likely to continue
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear for
covid19
and they're giving my audience 20 off
snh masks
is the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david